[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's podcast a comedy podcast
where me and my brother John talk about
death and we answer people's questions
and give them dubious advice and bring
you all the week's news from both Mars
and AFC Wimbledon how you doing John Doe
I'm doing all right I'm surrounded by
darkness ah well I'm surrounded by light
I'm not really I'm actually doing I'm
doing fine I don't know why I said I was
surrounded by darkness
in an astonishing development what I've
now referred to as the long improbable
summer of Taylor Swift in Indianapolis
continues its it's perhaps it's actually
really loved here lovely here in
Missoula - I don't know if she played
there this week but it's it's 74 degrees
outside right now and it rained briefly
and I was like okay it's ended it's
finally ended the autumn has arrived but
there the leaves are changing and it
could not be more beautiful to watch the
yellow and red and appear throughout the
trees of Indianapolis the weather itself
remains just blissfully sunny well I'm
glad we get to talk about the weather
here on the podcast John I had my
customary post-convention
wave of depression crash on me yesterday
that's just something that happens and
so you know you're ready for it you know
what's gonna happen because I for those
of you who don't know I I my I run a
company that runs conventions it's very
like you work really hard to make this
thing happen and then it happens in the
New Deal egos well and then you feel
real good until you don't anymore
it's very strange you know and it
happens every time and and so I that
happened yesterday yeah it was still a
little bit reeling from it I had did you
take the day off what do you what do you
do in that situation uh well I tend to
not realize it's happening for a while
and so no I I just did my normal thing
which is good like the normal things
sort of like carry you through but then
what happened is I had this period of
not having anything to do and then and
then I immediately went in search of
people who might be on the internet
trying to make me angry I don't know why
that's the thing I do when I'm depressed
but I do I
go on the internet and I look for people
who dislike me well and to be clear you
mean sad more than depressed like you
don't mean that
yes I'm like crushing a pathological
problem just that there's a sadness that
descends upon you yeah yeah well yeah
like a mood that I am not in control of
and that is unpleasant right yeah no
that's no fun and then I I myself have
also been known to in those times go
onto the internet and try to find people
who hate me
so that I can um yeah feel bad about
myself and be confirmed in the knowledge
that everything I fear about myself is
true and that the world knows it all
right you want a short poem yeah let's
do it
god this is a funny podcast okay here's
our poem for today it's called the
skylight by Seamus Heaney it's actually
a recommendation by Jeremy you were the
one for skylights I opposed cutting into
the season tongue-and-groove of pitch
pine I liked it low enclosed it's
claustrophobic
nest up in the roof effect I like the
snuff dry feeling the perfect trunk we'd
fit of the old ceiling under there it
was all hutch and hatch the blue slates
kept the heat like midnight thatch but
when the slates came off extravagant sky
entered and held surprise wide open for
days I felt like an inhabitant of that
house where the man sick of the palsy
was lowered through the roof had his
sins forgiven was healed took up his bed
and walked away
the skylight by Seamus Heaney a funny
poem to start our comedy podcast I was
just thinking the other day about how I
like enclosed spaces and how my house is
my bedroom is very large it has a large
high ceiling it's not very large bedroom
but I was very high ceiling and I
sometimes I'm like I just want to be in
the closet hahaha I love I love glass
and steel homes I believed like my
favorite house is Philip Johnson's glass
house and I would be very happy living
in a house with no walls at all just so
long as I had extreme privacy nope
that's not how I feel I I used to when I
was a kid just make little nests in the
closet and and pack myself in there and
and spend time there and my parents
thought it was super weird our parent
yeah they were more my parents as well
Henry does that now so maybe he got that
from his uncle Hank let's answer a
question from our readers this is an
important one Hank and it's it's kind of
breaking news it's seasonally
appropriate it's from Abby she writes
dear John and Hank as Halloween is
approaching I have a question what are
your favorite costumes you've made Oh
hmm well I was Jane from Firefly once
last year I was hiccup and Katherine was
was the dragon what's the Dragons name I
mean our friendship is in danger right
now
I mean I obviously know this my wife was
the dragon for for Halloween the dragon
is a Night Fury I know what kind of
dragon it is why is that why is the
thing not in my head does he have any
tooth you have any toothless its
toothless in your agony toothless so we
were toothless and hiccup and and once
we were you were Napoleon and Deb from
Napoleon Dynamite which i think was my
favorite of all time
yeah you've always been better at
costuming then I have Sarah and I never
really dressed up we went to one costume
party together I can't remember what I
dressed up as but she dressed up as a
cowgirl and it was unconvincing I should
say also when I was Jane catherine was
Kaylee so we like to do the couple thing
Kaylee is my favorite she's adorable
she's startled in the favorite yeah um
so the only costume I can remember
properly loving is when I was a little
kid my mom made me a robot costume that
I wore like three or four Halloween's in
a row because it without robot costume
was awesome as magnificent yeah it was
just to remember that I felt like a
robot I was so jealous of it yeah I mean
when I was inside of it I felt like this
is it man
I did it I've become an artificial
intelligence it was great
plus I got candy what a what a great
what an underrated holiday I as an adult
I find it very strange here's the thing
I like about Halloween I like that we
send our children to strangers houses
yeah I think that that's that's a good
thing that we should do more often like
do more often as it as it as an adult I
don't want too many strangers coming to
my house if that's right right
right I like that we send children to
strangers houses I don't really like
that they send them to my house but I
like yeah but I'm willing to accept it
because I like the institution of of
just like okay let's have faith in
humanity for a day what I don't really
like is that the the payoff is just it
just awful awful food that is very bad
for children no it's I don't know it
seems like a strange thing to celebrate
I think it's fine by the way do you know
how many children have died in the
United States from poisoned Halloween
candy I believe it's zero it is 0 you
know how many times there's been a razor
blade inside an apple that's that's also
a zero also a zero yes this is a great
example of the sort of disparity between
actual data and and our perceptions it
just seems dangerous to send our kids
out and allow them to accept candy from
strangers but in fact it isn't yeah we
we are bad at understanding danger as
humans know terrible at it I mean I
can't tell you how many times I've
risked my life by applying hand
sanitizer while driving a car yeah that
is that is definitely a great example of
misunderstanding risk speaking of all
this Hank I think that this would be a
great time for a question from Caitlin
Caitlin says dear Hank and John through
listening to your podcast I get the
impression that John as a writer
believes humans are inherently evil
while Hank
as a scientist believes humans aren't
inherently good do you agree with this
viewpoint
no John doesn't believe humans are
inherently evil do you know I just
believe humans are inherently hungry
well I mean for at least part of the day
no I don't mean like physically hungry I
mean hungry I mean ambitious I mean that
that when necessary
you know homo homini lupus because
because you're hungry and ambitious and
and you you know the heart wants what it
wants kind of thing III don't think
people are bad I think that they're
they're hungry right well I think but I
think that there is also a lot of like
in addition to the hunger there
other motivations that are good that and
like of course what is good and bad but
I I the distinction between the the
author and the scientist is interesting
here that like if you take an objective
point of view people look like good
people and if you take a if you take a
more like you know you know imagining
possibilities maybe then humans look
more dastardly I don't know I mean yeah
I think that's an interesting point of
view i I don't think that I have to say
I don't think humans are good or bad I
think that they're good and bad I Henry
is obsessed I have a five and a half
year old son for new listeners to the
podcast my five and a half year old son
is obsessed with good and evil and you
know most of the stories that really
resonate with him whether it's you know
Star Wars or Ninjago or Penguins of
Madagascar like most of those stories
have good guys and bad guys and the good
guys are pretty darn good and the bad
guys are pretty darn bad and and then
there are the characters that Henry
calls complicated and I remember one
time he said he said daddy
Hulk smash is complicated is he and he
said yeah Hulk smash is complicated he's
because he's good and bad and I think I
think this is not just a just Hulk smash
I think in fact almost everyone is good
and bad and and I also think that like
in trying to do good you can do you know
horrible horrible evil and in trying you
know and in trying to do bad you can
also do good like it's just so hard to
it's so hard to sort it out yeah I think
that that what I mean when I say humans
are inherently good is that people are
bound by the contracts of culture and
and and that is one of the things that
we consider to be the good is that like
culture has rules and we tend to obey
them the other thing that I mean when I
say that humans are good is that in
general a lot of the motivations of
people are to make life better for the
people they love yeah I agree with that
I
I and I believe in empathy and I believe
that humans are capable of extraordinary
altruism I wouldn't go so far as to say
that people are good like you keep
saying in fact every time you say it I'm
wincing a little bit because it just
seems far too optimistic I don't know I
just I've met a lot of people and they
seem pretty nice
I agree almost all of the people that I
have ever met are good and and I will
say this I guess all the people I've
ever met are both good and broken but
most of all hungry I can't emphasize
enough how much I believe in human
hunger huh I guess okay let's move on we
can agree to disagree
people like people are good and hungry
and broken okay it's our first proper
disagreement Hank thinks that humans are
good I think that humans are good and
bad that's as close as we've ever come
to a real disagreement okay Hank we've
got another question this one is very
important and it comes from Adam who
writes Dear John and Hank I am a junior
in high school and I referee kids soccer
games first off Adam I just want to
pause to thank you for doing the Lord's
work this means I have a lot of
experience with angry parents yelling at
me why do you think adults are compelled
to yell at teenagers during sports games
and what should I do about it
Oh Adam this is such a good question it
is and I am so sorry that in refereeing
children's soccer games you a high
school junior are being treated by
parents as if you are an actual figure
of authority I think so I I I don't know
if this is gonna work but my my
suggestion to you I don't really know
how children's soccer games work but I
assume that it's just a bunch of people
standing along like there's no this is a
bunch of people standing around right
with like a line on the ground in some
some some goals yeah so go up to the
people before the game and say hi my
name is Adam I'm a junior over at the
school over at middle Dale high school
and I just wanted to say I'm gonna you
know I'm out here to like make sure
everybody has a good time and try and
make sure everybody doesn't get hurt and
and it's nice to meet you and then and
then
and maybe they will have some empathy
and realized that they are yelling at a
child yeah I actually agree with that
strategy and maybe also say just
actually say I am a person in addition
to pointing out that a junior in high
school because one of the weird things
about referees is that I have a theory I
have a theory actually that wearing
uniforms is a way of dehumanizing is a
way of dehumanizing the other okay so
like and that uniforms are kind of like
designed so that you don't have to think
about people as people one time when I
was in college I went to a girls
softball game was dating a member of the
softball team and I am a I'm just an
inveterate talker at public sporting
events and I don't even like you know
like Alice's is my daughter is too and
and when she plays soccer
I will even I won't criticize the
refereeing but I will comment upon it
just because it's the thing to do it's
part of the sporting event yeah exactly
it feels like it's part of the sporting
event so I remember anyway I was I was
criticizing seeing the strike zone at
this women's softball game at Kenyon
College Division three school and the
umpire just took off his his mask and he
turned around and he looked at me and
with the moment he looked at me I was
like oh my god I'm so sorry
who had eyes I just realize you're a
person like all the other people oh yeah
so Adam I think what's happening is that
you know people aren't thinking of you
as a person they're thinking of you as
sort of an obstacle to their child's
success and and when you do that you
know like your it feels like someone is
opposing your child and you're very
defensive of your child but I really
like Hanks suggestion of just going up
to them before the game and being like I
am 16 I am doing this out of the
goodness of my heart
yeah I'm gonna make fifty dollars over
the next three hours so maybe don't be a
jerk to me yeah I think I think also
like like even it you know people
continue recognize first of all that
it's not it's probably not most of the
people and and second
you know the people who are doing it it
might just be that like this is the way
they experience sports you yell at the
referee that's a thing you do and and
and at a large sporting event like that
they have been trained how to behave at
sporting events at that you certainly do
that of course you do that
I am very I kind of anti this I feel
very strange we have it we have a hockey
team in Missoula that is like sort of
it's like the lowest professional level
you can be and the a lot of the players
on the team are like 16 15 even years
old so like they've dropped out of high
school to start their professional
hockey careers it's very weird and when
the when when the crowd starts jeering
these children of the other team I'm
just like no no no stop or like when
they get in a fight and like it feels
very strange to like like would like be
a group of people who are cheering for
children to fight each other like that
just it seems very very wrong very weird
and and I like I like very much that I
get to watch live hockey even if it is a
very low level of hockey but I am I'm
often disturbed by the audience I'm
pretty concerned I have to say by the
fact that you live in pond em and you
guys are doing the Hunger Games there in
Missoula basically yes that's weird
uh-huh yeah with really bad pizza oh god
Adam you are a person this is not about
you it's not even about the quality of
the refereeing is the other thing like a
really well refereed game will still get
a lot of jeers I don't know I think it's
something that's inherent to this to an
inherent problem within the sport is
that is that it's the black and white
striped uniform I think I agree uniforms
are definitely dehumanizing and that is
part of their goal we have a question
from Jillian who asks dear Hank and John
Gotham uses the bat-signal
a modified searchlight til that Batman
know that they need help during times of
crisis knowing what little I do about
the functionality of searchlights
admittedly a very small amount wouldn't
the light need to be projected against
something reflective or solid in order
for it
be visible and not escape unnoticed into
the great beyond of space ultimately
does this mean that Batman only works on
cloudy nights well first off you lien
every night is cloudy in the city of
Gotham I think that I think that is the
clear answer and and from a scientific
standpoint I think that what what uh
what is factual is if Gotham happens to
be in a very humid area no matter
whether it's cloudy or not you could see
that a searchlight was being shined into
the sky if you lived in Phoenix Arizona
you might not be able to see it
reflecting off of any of the particles
in this in the air but if it was in
Orlando Florida you definitely could is
Gotham Chicago
well Gotham is a fictional city it's
sometimes it's Chicago sometimes it's
New York occasionally it's Pittsburgh at
least judging from the movies so it's my
question and I was when we were kids
there were a lot of search lights in
Orlando remember like that Club would
open or whatever and you guys see the
searchlights aha I remember being able
to see the beams of light you know
moving around because they were moving
searchlights I don't remember being able
to see like the thing the equivalent of
the bat-signal like I could see the beam
of light I couldn't see the equivalent
of the bat-signal I'm wondering yes from
absolutely not you cannot project like
there is not a way to project an image
onto a cloud for a number of reasons now
if clouds can be fairly flat on the
bottom that certainly isn't always the
case but they are far enough away that
it would be very difficult to focus
light in that way you met people to do
with lasers but you could not do it with
a normal a searchlight a searchlight
style of thing you certainly couldn't
like just strap a logo on top of a
searchlight and and have that be
projected into the sky the good news
though is during the 80s Batman got a
beeper you could just what you do is you
just call me is it five five five one
two one two wait so the whole bat-signal
thing is it's just a lie it's just a
visual it's just made up no yeah I mean
it's a comic it's a it's a great trope
for a comic absolutely I love it I don't
I don't dislike it or anything but yeah
no that's not
that's fine sorry that's a bummer yeah I
mean humans are inherently evil John I
didn't say they were inherently evil I
said they were inherently complicated
I'm hungry
oh man anyway today's podcast is brought
to you by Batman Batman totally
unreachable apparently he has a paper
okay today's episode of dear Hank and
John is brought to you by angry parents
yelling at referees it's a whole group
of people who really just haven't worked
out reality quite rightly today's
episode of dear Hank and John is brought
to you by human evil human evil Hank
doesn't think it exists and yet it keeps
happening and of course I think it
exists and of course this podcast is
brought to you I don't know that I do
even we have another question this one
is from Rory who asks dear Hank and John
I've recently been watching old
vlogbrothers videos and in 2011 you guys
were talking about stocks in the evil
company Warner Chilcott which by the way
is my prescription drug prices a lot and
so I told people to not buy their stock
which I guess that was my active
activism anyway it's got me thinking how
does one buy stocks so if either of you
had any insights into this and any
advice on whether I can or should invest
in stocks that would be greatly
appreciated best wishes Rory PS keep in
mind that I'm 17 years old yeah you
should definitely buy stocks if you're
17 years old and you have a bunch of
money sitting around Rory yeah I mean
this is that this is the time to do it
yeah when you have a 55 year investment
horizon so Rory the answer to your
question is that a share of a stock is
essentially a very small percentage of
that company so if I buy a hundred
shares of Warner Chilcott stock I then
own some fraction of the company Warner
Chilcott I can later sell that fraction
of the company to someone else it may be
worth more or less depending on whether
you know Warner Chilcott has grown its
business in the intervening time while
I've owned the stock and then there's
another way that you can potentially
make money from owning stocks which is
dividends if Warner Chilcott makes a
profit of say
you know $100,000,000 they they may pay
out a portion of that profit to their
shareholders to their owners in the form
of dividends that's as for how you buy a
stock you most mostly these days people
set up accounts with brokerage firms you
know from fidelity you may have seen
commercials for companies like etrade or
a TD Ameritrade on TV those those
companies are basically places where you
can go to buy tiny amounts of companies
and also sell them yeah and the reason
why stocks are tend to be a good deal is
because because the economy has grown in
the past and we believe that it will
continue to grow and and and indeed if
it doesn't then there are larger
problems that we would need to face and
the yeah so the the stock market tends
to grow over the last you know a hundred
years at around 6% per year which is a
very good return on your investment and
if you put you know $100 in now that
$100 would be a lot a lot of money by
the time you retire and that is kind of
the way to make sure that you have you
know can take care of yourself into old
age yeah actually you know what I'm
gonna do I'm just gonna find out what
Rory so let's assume that a 6% interest
rate compounding a $100 initial
investment that's gonna be $1,800 in 50
years assuming a 6% return and that you
reinvest the money that you make so
based on the averages of how the stock
market has fared over the last hundred
years in 50 years you could turn your
hundred dollars into the equivalent of
$1,800 today now is it gonna feel that
good in 50 years to have $1,800 or is it
gonna feel better now to have a brand
new pair of sneakers that's up for
that's up for you to decide not yeah I'm
not here to make you decisions
do not buy just one stock no that is a
very bad idea
no the great thing about the great thing
about financial tools now is that
they're so cheap that you can buy lots
and lots of stocks at the same time even
with a relatively small investment like
a hundred dollars it's important stuff I
mean it's kind of exciting it's
incredibly important and it is
horrifying to me that we had to learn it
as adults and everyone else has to yeah
as adults and that it's not part of like
education well we should do a crash
course Personal Finance John we've
talked about it I would and maybe
someday we'll be able to but in the
meantime you can watch the financial
diet our new channel that we're
producing with lovely people in in New
York City it's called the financial diet
you can google it and learn about how to
live in the world and make dreams come
true without destroying your life I I
wish that all of your answers were in
the form of songs Hank let's have a
question that was my jingle for the
financial day Ryan who asks Dear John
and Hank I'm 20 years old
I'm from Texas but go to university in
Scotland and I'm gay when I try to think
about who I am as a person I usually
make lists of adjectives and facts about
myself like the things I just mentioned
but that doesn't really feel like me at
a time in my life when I'm still working
to find my niche I have to evaluate
myself in terms of those around me to
figure out whether or not I fit in with
them but at the same time I'm also
trying to find myself how do i balance
the need to understand myself in terms
of the surface level performances I put
on for others and the need to understand
myself out of an external context or is
there even a difference between the two
the subject line of that email by the
way Hank am I the some of my recent
emojis which is a beautiful beautiful
subtle thing yeah and and that's a big
question one that I've been trying to
write about for the last four years so I
hopefully Hank will have a good answer
well I believe strongly for myself that
there is no such thing as myself that is
separate from my experiences and my
values and like there's not a like
there's not a core me that just connects
to like what I you know like like to all
of the things that that like we
described as identities or like I am
just those things like in the way that a
calculator
there isn't a calculator if you take all
of the calculators parts away you know a
calculator is like the circuit board and
some buttons in this the solar panel I'm
holding a calculator in my hand right
now and some plastic and and like that
is the calculator so like and then if
you take away all of its parts it isn't
anymore there's nothing there there's
it's not like a bunch of stuff that's
tied to a calculator yeah I don't want
to make your life harder but what if you
take away one part of the calculator
like what if you took away the button
for the number-9 is it still a
calculator yeah it's still a calculator
and at some point you take away enough
things yeah I get it but it like that
that that's not that's not the metaphor
I'm trying to make that's not connected
to the metaphor I'm making a metaphor
I'm making is simply that that like I am
just a bunch of things a bunch of
expectations my the story that I tell
myself about me like there's no there's
no core thing that I try it that I met
have managed to uncover it is just a
bunch of things that have happened and
that I tied together with narrative
structure in my mind and I can change
that and I can and and like certainly
there are like there I have
predispositions toward emotions and and
maybe those are slightly different than
other people's but the idea that like I
I just can't get behind the idea that
there is a thing that I've that I've
been trying my whole life to uncover
that then I can be my true self when in
fact my true self is just an
amalgamation of my my predispositions
and my values and my experiences yeah I
mostly agree with that I think the only
thing that I yeah and and I think that
you know Ryan's question in your
response to me are both sort of
indicative of this shift that we've had
in the last hundred years of human
history away from away from the soul or
the idea of the soul as being sort of
cool I mean let's say Western history or
- personhood well I I wouldn't
necessarily say well I mean ism is very
much about this idea of like the self
not being a structured thing and that it
that is a constructive thing that people
create for themselves right but within
Buddhism in almost all sects of Buddhism
there is a-there there is something
inside of you that survives into the
next life in the karmic circle so like
there is still some essence that is
capital y-you and that idea has has been
I think deeply challenged in the last
100 150 years by industrialization by
you know by globalization by and and and
to some extent by scientific discovery
but I think um I I am very interested in
in like at what point I stopped being me
like you know if I had a for instance I
have I have a friend who had a traumatic
brain injury before I knew them right
and if you speak to people who knew my
friend before the traumatic brain injury
they always say like oh he was a
different guy then but he wasn't but he
also was like right and and so this is
that's like a very difficult like it's a
difficult I think to get around get your
head around when it comes to identity
and understanding yourself and also like
understanding other people you know
right but I'm also a different guy than
I then I was when I was 16 like their
otherwise you become different then
right yeah yeah change occur yeah that's
why that's what I think is so
interesting about the calculator
metaphor that you don't find interesting
about it which is okay but like I am
interested in like if I take things away
and add things like at what point does
the calculator is the calculator just no
longer a calculator and it becomes
something else entirely like it becomes
a computer or it becomes you know a
robot or something
I don't have an easy answer for that
question and I don't think there is an
easy answer and I think Hank is
absolutely right that like you you are
you know the sum of your identities and
experiences and feelings and that you
aren't you know you aren't separate from
those things and that that's part of the
reason that understanding your
identities and being able to process
your experiences in a way that helps you
to create itself like I think that's
part of the reason that's such an
important process and like anytime
somebody is sort of dismissive of that
process
particularly among young people I get
really angry because I think it's uh you
know I think it's important that I think
it's valuable and I also think it's
something that not just teenagers and
not just young people they're doing and
there's there's a there's also a sense
that like there are some people who just
like have found it very easy to know who
they are yeah and and that often comes
with some some like you know just being
like people expected them to be being
you know sort of like if you grew up in
Texas for example you would probably not
be a gay person moving to Scotland
depends on the Texan there's two texts
depends on the Texas very true very true
but like if you sort of fit into society
as it exists then you you you it's sort
of a less difficult path and and I like
I kind of fit into my expectations of me
early on in my life a lot like it was
just like oh you're a nerd and like do
nerd stuff and I was like Kay
like you like whether that was like do
well on tests and enjoy Star Trek or get
punched by people at school like I just
did all those things and like there was
an identity for me to fit into really
easily and so I did that and that like
like it's when you realize that your
identity is something that you construct
for yourself it can be liberating and
terrifying and like I think that that's
what it should be and I I i think that
like stripping yourself a little bit of
like the constructed identity that's
been applied to you or that you've
applied to yourself is necessary to do
sometimes so I guess all we're saying is
that this is a healthy process and that
there is not an end to it and there
doesn't need to be right yeah okay well
that doesn't help me with my book much
but hopefully it's helpful to Ryan is a
great is a great question I have me like
I think yeah I think that Ryan needs a
whole series of podcasts on what the
self is you can go and watch some good
TED talks on what what's what the self
is you just type in like identity and to
Ted and to the Ted website the problem
with all of these all of these self can
all these ways of new ways of looking at
the self whether they're constructed or
derived the problem to me is that all of
them seem to
imagine a self that I don't I don't know
that it exists in a body that's 90% not
me 90% of the cells in my body are
bacteria like am I am i me or am I
actually just like essentially a colony
but but by weight by weight you're the
vast majority of you is you the bacteria
cells are very small by weight you're
almost all you find that very unhelpful
I can't I cannot / I cannot overstate
how well a hundred percent of your brain
cells are are you so there's that yes I
don't know I I hope anyway I'm very I'm
very distressed in general I have to say
about like what how how we understand
what constitutes personhood and how we
and how we sort of give or acknowledge
personhood in others and I don't think
that we do a good job of that right now
and I think one of the reasons we don't
do a particularly good job that is
because we don't think about it very
much we don't think about what actually
makes people people or would actually
you know how to actually treat a person
as a person rather than treating them as
you know so many people are treating
Adam the high school referee right we're
just like you know like you're sort of
like off hand construction of a person
because of course you can't like you
can't just don't have enough cognitive
resources to try and imagine everybody
the way you imagine yourself no not
nearly enough but you should have enough
cognitive resources to be able to confer
personhood on to others but III think
increasingly that personhood is
something that is that is both like won
and conferred it's something that's both
like achieved by you know like because I
don't think I don't think people who are
benefiting from power structures
particularly like to confer personhood
upon people who are oppressed and not
being treated by the world as as full
people but I also think that it is it is
conferred in the sense that like we all
have to agree that each other is human
like we all have to agree
one another is is a real person right
and so and so people who are afraid to
to or dislike the idea of bestowing that
personhood on people create
constructions by which they can they can
demonize them in their own minds and and
and have themselves believe that those
people deserve their their situation or
that or that there's some threat that
they represent to their way of life that
is not about like just you know the the
fair distribution of resources but it's
about like the destruction of something
greater than than any individual human
etc which is something that we sure do
see a lot and and that I've been
thinking a lot about lately I don't know
I don't doubt now I'm back in the
darkness in this comedy podcast well
it's bound to happen we are all going to
die not just not just we're all gonna
die Hank it's much worse than that
everyone we love is going to die and
everything that we work for will
disappear into dust
everything forever and you sometimes eat
poop not just a little bit either it is
just a little bit it's just a lot of
different poop you just need a lot of
eat a little bit of poop oh speaking of
which it's time to get to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon because we've
we've gone too far down the rabbit hole
of darkness and we're too we'vewe've
it's almost recursion at this point just
sort of spinning around this idea of
selfhood
thank you for the excellent question I'm
sorry that we answered it so poorly and
ended up ended up in this recursive
nightmare but um we're gonna move on to
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
let's begin with the news from Mars Hank
I saw the Martian
oh good how was that I thought it was
great can you can you I have some
questions okay ask me some questions
about the Martian could you really grow
potatoes on Mars using only your poop
and Martian soil no that's a bummer I
mean they're working on ways to do it I
mean basically what you need is you need
to rinse the soil real good because
there's some stuff in the soil that
would uh that would eat potatoes not
like not like consume them but just
harsh chemicals that would oxidize the
roots
which would make it impossible to grow
so you need to wash all that stuff out
of the soil you'd need more water than
Mark Watney had but but maybe maybe real
life mark Watney if that ever happened
would have access to more water because
they'd have some kind of water
production system in place that was more
significant than the one he he had but
yeah it is absolutely possible to grow
potatoes on Mars but not only with human
poop and Martian soil and water another
question for you
to what to what extent is that what Mars
looks like that's what that's what Mars
looks like I mean that was one of my
favorite parts of the movie some people
complained that there was like a lot of
just like like shots of Mars in there
like come on get with the story and I'm
like Shh I just I
if the whole movie was just renders of
the surface of Mars with with like
little dust devils rushing across it I
would I would be perfectly happy yeah
that was also my favorite part of the
movie was just the Mars parts just the
parts where you were just looking at
Mars and he was a tiny little person
yeah I thought it was a very enjoyable
movie though I have to say yeah you know
I I think I liked the book but I think
it was it was sort of made to be a movie
I think it was a better better movie
than a book because sometimes it's
sometimes that happens yeah absolutely
and sometimes people get angry at me
when I say that it doesn't happen that
often or when I imply that books are a
more enjoyable experience than a movie
because I'm being an elitist dillhole
but I like books a lot and also I feel
like they're the underdog in this fight
so don't you feel like maybe movies are
doing okay and don't need to be
predicted so harshly this is a little
bit of a personal thing that I have
experienced in my life that really has
no bearing on reality yeah or this
podcast yeah seriously speaking of which
is there any other news from Mars other
than the fact that I saw the Martian or
is that the big news that that's that's
big news that the there is also a recent
report that was put together and this
has bearing on a question that was asked
to us by Samuel who asks dear Hank and
John why aren't there moon bases we hear
a lot about when I go to Mars but it
seems that to me that if we're serious
about living on other planets we would
go to the moon first to test the
technology it's real close so why aren't
there any moon bases well a recent
port from MIT I think I'm not entirely
sure if it was yes it was a recent
report from MIT says that if we want to
go to Mars it indeed might be a really
good idea to set up some moon bases and
particularly set up a moon base that
would produce fuel that we could use to
get to Mars now there's this huge
problem that we have in getting to Mars
and that huge problem is called Earth
it's very heavy it is hard to get stuff
off of it because it is so heavy it has
a lot of gravity and so in order to get
to Mars you have to not only launch all
the stuff you want to get to Mars but
you have to launch all of the fuel that
it takes to get to Mars and also all of
the fuel necessary to push the fuel to
Mars and the fuel necessary to push the
fuel to push the fuel it's a big problem
it's why it's hard to get to space but
if we launched some little robots to the
moon that just created fuel using
electricity from the Sun or from nuclear
generators and and water and some other
stuff on the surface of the Moon then we
would be able to get to Mars much more
easily by having a sort of pit stop at
the moon because you can launch fuel off
of the moon much less expensively
because the moon is much lighter than
the earth so your proposal is to build
it a nuclear power plant on on the moon
well I mean a lot of a lot of space
stuff is powered by by nuclear
generators of one kind or another so
that's not it that's not a crazy idea no
it's just nice to know it's nice to know
how the human experiment will land well
I mean it's the moon what's the work
what's the worry yeah I know and when we
blow it up if when we blow it up we're
gonna find out just how big of a deal
well first of all you can't blow up the
moon with even a very large nuclear
weapon that's not gonna happen and to
this might this might be solar-powered
it might be solar-powered John or three
it might be more of a thermoelectric
generator which is just like basically a
lump of radioactive stuff that is just
hot that is used for electricity not not
a nuclear reactor sometimes I feel like
you haven't even seen the movie
Armageddon like it's just not even part
of your scientific understanding of the
world I did recently read a book in
which the moon explodes and it turns out
to be a very bad thing for her oh yeah I
think I reviewed that book in the New
York Times Book Review actually oh
really you read seven Eve's
nope different book amazing oh wow
different books explode with moon's
exploding wow it happens all the time in
literature pretty well I mean that's all
fine and good but let's get to the real
news Hank AFC Wimbledon all right owned
by its fans just the most wonderful
institution that humans have ever made
what is good of us is all contained
inside of AFC Wimbledon so we played we
played Morecambe on Saturday the 17th of
October and we lost and we didn't just
lose we lost five to two so that was
that was not good and then this Tuesday
as I'm talking to you which is yesterday
we went to Accrington Stanley and we
played them away and we've never beaten
or tied Accrington Stanley in the last
four years of playing them and we gave
up three goals and we won four to three
it was amazing
we were to kneel down in the first half
but we've got this new striker Lyle
Taylor he's 15 I mean he's 25 15 just a
child
he's 15 we do have a couple of we do
have a couple of legit 15 year olds but
he's not one of them while Taylor is a
he's a very promising striker though
he's had a kind of a journeyman's career
like a lot of Ligue 2 players he he
played in Scotland for a club called
Patrick thistle and he is actually
Montserrat Ian you know where Montserrat
is Hank I couldn't tell you well it is a
it is it is in the Caribbean Sea it is a
Caribbean island and he plays for the
Montserrat Ian national team in fact he
scored a goal for them it's pretty you
know yeah he's a he's an international
goal scorer okay but he he scored two
goals in this game for four AFC
Wimbledon we came from two no back and
one for three and put ourselves in a
situation now where you know you don't
like to get ahead of yourself certainly
but there's there's some promising
things going on over at AFC Wimbledon
right dead center in the middle
the table ten points from last place ten
points from first place on 19 points but
you know I feel scared but good well so
all they have to do is score ten points
in the next game right cuz that's how
that's how it works well no you only get
three points for a win one point for a
tie and zero points for a loss so we
would have to win three games and tie
one well the best team in the league
doesn't play any okay I see alright that
makes nine that would that would be
ideal yeah but it was an absolute yeah
it was an absolute thriller of a game
and and there were only a hundred and
twenty five AFC Wimbledon fans who were
able to make the you know the Tuesday
evening trip to Akron can Stanley but
they enjoyed a heck of a game and I'm
starting to feel I'm starting to feel
like this team is coalescing a little
bit so we'll see we'll see how things go
but I it seems good right now alright
well congratulations on your mediocre
season thus far John thank you so much
so what did we learn today John yeah we
learned that when we start talking about
self or when we start talking about
getting rocket fuel to go to Mars we
quickly get into a recursive spiral and
we learned that it is important to have
a diversified stock portfolio if you are
capable to the best through index funds
at it at a at a brokerage firm such as
fidelity or each raid or TD Ameritrade
none of whom sponsor our podcast just
know clear also we are not certified
financial planners please God do not
listen to us and of course we learned
that seamus heaney like skylights and
Hank like small enclosed spaces we also
learned that John had the best robot
costume of all time for three years when
he was a child and I never got to wear
it and maybe by the third year you were
just wearing it so I could well it all
worked out in the end Hank because you
were able to use your anger over me
having the better costume as a child to
become the better costumer as an adult
so I hope there's some comfort in that
for you yeah I think I've just I spent
an awful lot of time trying to make up
for that and maybe I don't even like
wearing cool costumes I'm just trying to
make up for my scarred childhood of not
having a good enough costume for a
couple I mean sure I had great costumes
I'm sorry I feel bad about saying that
too and I'm sure my mom if she's
listening wouldn't be sad to hear that I
feel as if my costumes were inferior
they were not I love you mom this pod
gasps ow she's listening she's a great
she's a great friend of the pond thank
you for listening to this episode of
dear Hank and John I am Hank and that
guy is John we are always open to more
questions you can send them to dear Hank
and John at gmail.com this podcast
certainly no beat dear Hank and John at
gmail.com no dear just Hank and John at
gmail.com I'm sorry everyone and what
would we be without your questions just
a bunch of news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon and who wants that
if you end a short poem as well you can
also send questions via Twitter hashtag
dear Hank and John this podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins our theme
music is by gunnarolla and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]